difficile pour la gérante de ce bar
exigu du centre-ville d'envisager une
prochaine réouverture
ici les deux mois d'inactivité risque de
se prolonger
en attendant il faut bien continuer à
payer le loyer pour la gérante la
solution d'un éventuel report des
échéances est jugé insuffisant
on a l'habitude de payer un loyer par
mois à la réouverture on sera pas
capable de payer de loyer par mois sauf
si leur seul coup on se retrouve avec
deux fois plus de personnes dans le bar
ce qui peut être difficilement
envisageable au vu des normes à
respecter avec d'autres petits
commerçants la gérante a donc décidé de
lancer une tribune un document dans
lequel les entrepreneurs mettent en
avant la loi pour demander au bailleur
l'annulation des loyers durant la
période de confinement
les articles du code civil sont vraiment
dans notre cas de figure c'est à dire
dans un cas de force majeure on était
contraint pour beaucoup pour beaucoup de
professions de devoir fermer nos
commerces et donc aucune rentrée
d'argent sans rentrées d'argent c'est
très difficile de payer un loyer de
payer ses charges et tout le reste
2 par dupuis ça j'ai une famille à
nourrir derrière tout ça et je ne veux
pas laisser dans le besoin la tribune a
déjà réuni une vingtaine de commerces
indépendants un acte solidaire pour la
gérante de ce restaurant a la chance
d'avoir ici un propriétaire qui a été
assez très empathique sur sur le sujet
sur un mois de loyer
on sait pas encore l'évolution sur les
mois qui viennent mais
voilà donc je me sent évidemment
concerné et puis sur la totalité du
confinement de toute façon on sait qu'on
aura pas de loyaux faire donc c'est
important
les gérants de bars et restaurants
demeurent les principaux signataires de
cette tribune un secteur pour lequel la
reprise d'activité restent encore floues
et incertaine